[Music]
it looks like i'm making
an inward circle
might go into the table
looks like that
and only because you don't know what to
look at
okay
so let's look at something
um
as i move into the tencon
my body
i don't why what is your fear on this
side are you hurt
is it your shoulder or knee no uh get
more of your center going no no no no
there you go lock your center this is
not locking your center lock your center
okay
cut it
all right so back to me
um
as i keep this on an inward
trajectory
i can never get in his back because he's
always moving with me if i follow the
rule that he has to keep moving
so if he if i break the rule where he
can stop and then i get myself there
yes but
that's a rude awakening waiting to
happen okay luca must keep moving it
means i must keep moving okay
so if i'm going inward every time again
again
we haven't done anything that scary
okay as i try to move this shoulder to
him
this arm keeps moving
where i want to be where i want to be
away from me
so you always get this gap right here do
you see
and so you're trying to do kota gas from
here right second you go back he's gonna
turn into you and there's that thing
boom
the
tesla bucky is outward
it's it's outward it's this
that's the body
so just like that technique is not here
i know a lot of people do it like that
but that's not it
this hat is going this way
this way
turn
[Music]
so
let's look so the first thing to look
for
is i can't ever get there
can't ever get there
there's always this space between us
second thing how do i know when i'm
doing the outward spiral and not the
inward spiral
in the outer spiral
the wrists
on the elbow train the indian yang value
so again
split the torso up
here you have your dowel line then you
have a yid line and a young line okay
when you do the inward spiral
this stays on the yawn line
in the outward spiral change
yin line
out goes to the young one this goes this
way
if you don't understand this grit
the elbow must go inside the hand
the elbow goes inside
the hat
not
the hand inside the elbow
no
[Music]
i'm doing my tampon
you go oh that's wrong already i already
can tell that's wrong the elbow's on the
outside of the hat
this hand goes this way
this hat goes this way you see it's on
the outside okay
and i have to come back
i have to make
all of that work and now
i'm not going to be pulling them in i'm
actually keeping them out
boom keeping him out okay
oh
there it is elbow inside elbow inside
it's just i don't stop here
elbow inside
whoa
this
cool
there you go
the same
thing
[Music]
otherwise you won't stay in the back
okay so
it's
it is very common that you hear or you
might even think that you know you're
the center of the technique
he's orbiting around you okay
then your mind goes oh
centrifugal energy but if you think
about an orbiting body like a planet
if it's only centrifugal energy it would
crash into it
there is some centripetal energy there's
some outward going force if you think in
terms of your yin and yang
i can't just be one
i have to do both okay so it can't be
i'm trying to bring him in
i'm trying to bring him in and i'm
trying to make him go
i
i am he's going in with my
ted
um ashley tsubaki and my thai savage but
he's going out with my tesla
okay do not pull him in the the body
where the footwork does the centripetal
okay this is keeping him out he tries to
come in he can't he's not coming in okay
he can't come in close to me he can't
close to me he can never close to me you
see i'm not going like this
he can't close to me whoa this is
keeping them out out
okay so
even though you're picturing orbiting an
orbiting body
picture an orbiting body they're not
crashing in the planets are not crashing
into the sun okay there's some energy
that's keeping them out
next mistake
it won't do you any good if you get
yourself there and then you unlock his
body okay because then they can come in
and come in so i'm trying to do
the technique i'm trying to keep him out
it's outward energy okay and now i
unlock his body and he can pivot around
his shoulder he's not going to do
anything there's the strike
so let's micro drill
the body lock will lighten the load okay
in the technique
i had to lock his body
through
that rotational energy here i just have
the mass of his body that's the energy i
gotta deal with so again what do i not
want
there's no free movement of his arm
there's no free movement through space
you see why not that's not gonna work
okay
oh as i touch it's his whole body his
whole body's mood
touching the body his whole body is
moving whole body
the arm cannot move through space
touch
no stop no slap no slack
touch in his body in his body in his
body
in his body
no
in his body his body moves
that's how you can move it back
okay
try it
so it look to you i can see what you're
trying to do it looked to you
like you're taking all the slack out
of his joints
and then you turn his joints but you can
see that's different on his body you can
see that
okay but the other thing you ignored was
how did you get what happened to his
body when you got there all the time it
took to get there so if you watch his
body nothing's happening to his body
there's what you see so you broke that
rule okay
you're going to be you're in his center
so if he's pushing and like ground
vector you're in the center okay uh so
there's my coq
in
the way that i have
taken these internal skills is just to
simplify it there's just two
okay
there is a separating internal skill and
there is a commune a communion internal
skill there's not
two
four of them eight of them just they're
all the same and they all ultimately are
just
neither one
okay
um so
if if i'm here and i can be in his
center
here and that's the separating skill and
then i can be
with the communion skill okay
so the separating skill is tokyo and the
communion skill is ikey okay
well it doesn't change in these little
micro drills that we're doing it doesn't
change doesn't change whether i do a
micro drill or not it doesn't change
whether he's grabbing me or not okay
here is just the technique i do it in
the technique
so in his center
i come around it's in his center and
this is how i get his body
oh and his body okay
so i do the technique shown here and
when i come around i don't take it off
here it's off and then you tighten these
joints
so let me show you this
i'm going to do
uh
okay
and you're going to go well you can do
this joint style you see
why don't you guys do it the other stuff
too
the other stuff in his body
or just take all the slack out of the
joints
and it feels different doesn't it
okay
so to the uk
you take all the slack out of their
joints it's going to hurt
that is not martial it is not martial
because it's pain compliance not
everyone has the same
or lack of pain tolerance
also if you break the lever
that's it you lose control okay so even
if i'm in cross-country even if i'm in
nicole i'm not i'm in i'm in his body in
the same way it's just the knee kill
shape knead the shape
okay then i don't break the wrist
there's no chance of breaking the lever
the lever okay
so same thing here if i go like this
and i take all the slack out of this
joint
if i break it he won't fall so i'm not
controlling his center okay
so if i'm here and i'm in his center
it's the same thing i'm in his center
so i'm showing you that
when i take one hand away it's not that
i'm push pull and lock the joints out
okay
so i'll come around
and
that's
without the joints being locked out okay
so just like i can do nikki in what
looks like you're locking the joints out
no i'm no i'm not i'm not i'm not in his
body
with the hand position
you can do it
higher elbow wrist well you could do it
at the wrist too
it doesn't matter
you got it
so don't have him
stay still
and you get all this and now you've got
the joint tension do you see
because what what were you doing all
this time you're staying still saying
still
got it okay